MARIA: Hi everyone.
My name is Maria and
I work here at Google
in a product excellence team.
And thank you for
joining us today
in person and over live stream.
It's great to see interest
in design at Google.
And I'd also like to thank
my co-organizers, Sergey
and Morris, for
making this happen,
as well as the Talks
at Google team here.
So today we're excited to
welcome Dr. Barry Katz, who's
going to talk about the history
of design of the Silicon
Valley.
Barry has five different jobs.
He is a fellow at the IDEO.
He is also a professor of
industrial and interaction
design at the California College
of the Arts in San Francisco.
He is a consulting professor
in the Design Group,
Department of Mechanical
Engineering at Stanford.
He is also an
innovation consultant
to governments and
companies around the world.
And he is a book author.
BARRY KATZ: That's five.
MARIE: That's five.
I said five, yeah.
And today he's here to talk
about the history of design
in the Silicon Valley, the
topic of his latest book.
And I've been lucky
to be Barry's student.
And I think that we're here
up for a really great talk.
BARRY KATZ: Thank you.
Thank you Maria.
So I think I need the microphone
for the remote people.
Google is like this
huge vacuum cleaner
that's sucking up talent
from all around the Bay
Area and the world.
So it's been a real
pleasure to see so many
of my former colleagues,
students, friends,
old friends, new
friends, from all five
of those reference points
that Maria referred to.
And it's true.
I do all of those
things and I have
a lot of lunches on
Caltrain, which as you know
does not have a restaurant.
I'm moving around a lot.
What I would like to
talk about with you
is the formation of a design
profession in Silicon Valley.
And I thought I would
start with a little bit
of self-promotional advertising.
So forget that.
But I did just published
a book, "Make It New,"
which is derived from an
exhortation of the poet
Ezra Pound in 1934 when he
delivered this manifesto
under the title "Make It
New" in which he called
for a revival of our culture.
And that kind of seemed
like an appropriate way
to think about design in
Silicon Valley, which I think
has been a neglected,
curiously neglected
part of the story of the
success of the Valley.
So here's the proof.
What you've got on
that image on the right
is a page out of the 1979
Palo Alto phone book.
And it lists, in
that red perimeter,
every one of the design
consultancies in Northern
California, all nine of
them, including one called
Hovey-Kelley Design, which is
the only one that still exists,
although it's changed
its name a few times
and is now known as IDEO.
But they are, all
of the designers
in Silicon Valley squeezed
between detective agencies
and diaper services.
And there's not a whole lot.
So when I began
to-- I become very
curious about how we have
moved from this situation,
in which we were
absolutely not on the map,
to where we are today.
And I'm going to be arguing that
there are probably more design
professionals working within
50 miles of where you're all
sitting right now than
anywhere else in the world.
And that happened in
about 30, 35 years.
So I became very curious
about that phenomenon.
This is the first of a series
of stupid maps with logos
all over them that
you're going to see.
So I apologize for that.
But it is of course
our beloved Bay Area.
Those are the two
earthquake faults,
which make it a kind
of a fragile place.
My students refer to them
was my fault and your fault.
And what you're
seeing in the logos
are a selection of some of
the design consultancies
that operate in the Valley.
The original ones, which still
exist-- Lunar, IDEO, and Frog,
all founded around 1980.
And then they began to calve
off a second generation
and a third generation, and
now already a fourth generation
of smaller firms that
are spilling out,
such that today there are, as
I think I can probably argue
convincingly, more
designers working
in this area than anywhere
else in the world.
And part of the reason that
that is just so striking
is if you would
ask almost anybody
in about, let's say, 1980 when
this activity began to ratchet
up, what are the design
capitals of the world,
I think there would have
been a really easy consensus.
And you should disagree
with me if this
doesn't sound about right.
But it would have been
London for product design
and New York for graphics
and Paris for fashion
and Milan for furniture,
Tokyo for electronics,
Los Angeles for whatever
they do down there.
And if you had said, and
the San Francisco Bay Area,
I think you would have been
met with a blank stare.
There was virtually nothing
that distinguished the area
in terms of design.
And now we find ourselves
as the global epicenter
of professional practice.
The second piece of
it is, in addition
to the independent
design consultancies--
the IDEOs, the
Frogs, the Lunars,
and their second, third, and
fourth generation offspring--
practically every one of the
iconic companies of the Valley
has built a significant
internal design group.
So you've got about 200 and
some design professionals
working at Google.
There are about 180 UX
designers working at Uber.
Pinterest has about 40.
Quora has its team.
And we're starting to
see, ominously for some,
the arrival of
Chinese companies.
Alibaba has a design
group, Apple's
iconic industrial design
studio, and so on and so forth,
the result of
which is, as I say,
the beginnings of--
not the beginnings,
but we are well into the
building of a critical mass
of independent
consultancies plus product
oriented companies with their
own very significant design
populations.
And then the third
piece of it-- this
is not precisely a Silicon
Valley story, but in a sense
it is.
We are starting to see the
building of internal design
groups or design thinking
groups-- which is not
quite the same thing--
showing up in companies that
have no-- and organizations,
not just companies-- that have
no particular tradition
of being product oriented
or having any kind of
a design sensibility.
So what's going on when, within
the last three to five years,
Kleiner Perkins announces
that they have appointed
John Maeda, former
president of RISD,
as its first design partner?
Or when, what else, we've got
McKinsey, which is, I think,
an $8 billion
management consultancy
buying Lunar Design whole,
acquiring this design
competence?
And I could repeat
those kinds of stories--
Capital One acquiring Adaptive
Path, this wave of mergers,
acquisitions by large
organizations of design
companies in order to build
an internal design competence.
It's actually quite amazing.
The US Army has gotten
addicted to design thinking.
God help us.
I don't know where
that's going to take us,
what a prototype of a
war might look like.
And I will tell you
one quick story,
because I really love this one.
About a year ago,
McKinsey threw a big party
for a hundred of its
top corporate clients
to show off the new
acquisition that it acquired,
Lunar Design, a very
distinguished engineering
plus design organization
based in San Francisco, about
70 people.
And they had asked
me to MC the event.
And as I introduced each
of the McKinsey guys
who were the
architects of the deal,
they all got up in
front of the audience
and made a big deal out of
the fact, I'm wearing jeans.
I never thought I
would be wearing jeans.
But we're so cool now.
We're hanging with designers.
And then I looked over at my
three friends from Lunar Design
and they were all wearing suits.
Like we can play with
grown ups, there's
nothing to be afraid of.
We're not going to hurt you.
So we've got this
critical mass building up.
These are of course not
exclusively Silicon Valley
firms, but they testify to
the explosion of interest
in the design practice
and the design
mentality that absolutely
does have its roots here.
So this led me to a
series of questions
that I set out to
answer in the book.
And assuming that
nobody in this room
can read, they are, number
one, how did the Bay Area
move from relative obscurity
to become what I think
is the global epicenter of
professional design practice
in the world today?
Secondly, how did design
move from a marginal service
in which designers
are basically pleading
for an audience with
some engineering manager
somewhere to becoming a
strategic driver of some
of the world's most
important companies?
Now I'm thinking about
the week that Larry Page
became CEO of Google and
announced the launch of Project
Kennedy here.
In the past, he
said-- this is not me.
This is your boss-- that
Google has been driven
by engineering and analytics.
In the future, it will
be driven by design.
I think many people
in this room are still
waiting to see that happen.
But it's beginning.
And an acknowledgement
from the top
is a fairly extraordinary thing.
So how did design move from
being a marginal service
in which designers were trying
hard to convince somebody
in upper management or
in engineering teams
that they had a value to add
and they weren't simply cute,
to the increasingly
important role they are
playing across the spectrum?
And then third, how did
professional practice evolve?
So to be a designer in the early
stages of this story-- which
I'll get to in a
moment-- meant probably
you were packaging electronic
components in sheet metal
enclosures.
And if this is a design
audience, how many of you
guys are doing that?
That's not what it
looks like any longer.
There are probably still some.
But we now have this
amazing phenomenon
of designers working on
some of the thorniest, most
wicked, intractable problems
of human civilization today.
So designers working on
global poverty as a design
issue, urban violence
as a design issue,
on pediatric obesity, access
to maternal health facilities
as design problems--
very, very different.
How did that
evolution take place?
So what I'll do in
a few minutes now
is tell you a bit about
how I formulated my answers
to these questions in a project
that took me about six years.
And I have to say it was
a total labor of love.
I enjoyed it hugely,
interviewed about 200 people.
Normally my research
strategy was,
I would find myself
in conversation
with one of the important
figures in the story.
The last question was,
so, what's in your garage?
Oh, boxes.
What's in the boxes?
Papers.
What kind of papers?
I don't know, I haven't
looked at the goddamn things
in 30 years.
And then I'm six weeks
in Larry Tesler's garage
in Portola Valley looking
through all of this stuff.
In any case, the book is based
almost entirely on first person
original primary
source research.
And the stuff is there.
And it just required a lot of
digging and was loads of fun
to do.
OK, so I would like
to tell you kind
of a synopsis of some
of my findings organized
around one particular story
out of the large number.
So I spent time looking at the
technology companies of course.
The origins of design do not
start with Apple and Steve
Jobs.
That's the ghost of Steve Jobs
rising above the new Apple
campus.
But it goes back much further.
So I spent lots of time
looking at the tech companies.
The academic environment
of the Bay Area
is extremely important.
So I studied the nature
of design training, how
we design designers
in the engineering
environment of Stanford,
the arts school
environment of California
College of the Arts,
and in the public university
setting at San Jose
State, each of
which was critically
important in its own way.
Looked at the labs, which played
a very, very important role
from Stanford Research
Institute, now
SRI International, to
the famous Xerox PARC,
Atari Research Labs-- those
drug besotted hippies down there
were a major piece
of the story-- and up
to Interval Research.
I don't know if you're
familiar with that one.
But it was all a real eye
opening experience for me,
partly because my
beginning assumption
was that design
in Silicon Valley
began when Steve Jobs began
to hire the group that became
IDEO and Frog Design and Lunar.
And it turned out that that is
the midpoint of the story, not
the origins.
That was, to use our
favorite word, the pivot.
So for the origins,
we need to go back
to two iconic companies.
Hewlett-Packard is
still very much with us.
Almost the only
thing left of Ampex
is that sign, which you will
see as you're riding the Google
bus back up to Noe Valley.
They're missing
a P, and I always
think that American
Express stole the P
to get some free advertising.
And it looks
something like this.
August 1, 1951, a guy named
Carl Clement drove down
from Washington state with
his freshly minted University
of Washington industrial
design degree,
looked up an old
college roommate
who was working for a 250 person
instrument firm in Palo Alto
that some of you may have heard
of called Hewlett-Packard.
On a whim he
interviewed for a job.
He showed his
airbrushed portfolio
full of automotive interiors
and desk lamps and things.
The engineering manager,
an applied physicists
named Ralph Lee, looked over his
stuff and said it's very nice,
but we don't do that here.
But they gave him a
job none the less.
Because one day, it was noticed
that the insignias on the HP
packing crates blended
into the background
and were not visible.
And they had the idea that this
guy was a designer, whatever
the hell that meant,
might be able to help
improve the graphics.
So the result-- and that
is the first designer,
designer 1.0 of Silicon Valley.
The result was to get rid of
the beige cardboard background,
make it white so that
the HP logo would pop.
David Packard was driving
behind an HP truck one
day that didn't have
its rear door down
and he saw it and he
said that's really great.
And design begins in the Valley.
That is Bill Hewlett.
That is David Packard.
I like to say that Hewlett is
standing up because Packard
really was about 18 feet tall.
So the story begins
very much as a kind
of a branding story, which in
itself is not that interesting.
I have this great quote in
which as the design group, which
was one person,
tried increasingly
to gain a hearing within the
engineering environment of HP,
they let him in with
the instruction,
"You irritate my engineers,
you're outta here."
In time, the design
group increased
by orders of magnitude.
It went from one person to two
and from two people to four,
and swelled within
a decade to a total
of six people, this
sprawling design enterprise.
And they moved from rather
trivial projects of the sort
that I just said-- improving
graphics on cardboard boxes--
to the idea that we can
establish a coherent design
language.
This is actually, in
a way, an anticipation
of what Project Kennedy did
at Google when they set out
to integrate Maps and Search
and Gmail and the other products
in the platform and give them
kind of a family coherence.
So at the time of the second
phase of design at HP,
the HP catalog listed
something like 373 devices.
Each one of them was a
discrete self-standing entity.
They would have been
enclosed in mahogany boxes,
in aluminum with
mitered edges, sometimes
in no enclosures at all.
That was not on the
radar screen as part
of the offering of a company.
And the proposal was made
by the internal design group
that we can establish a
coherent language that
would help engineers to
identify an HP product anywhere
they saw it.
And these were
beloved instruments
in the technical
community across the US.
So this was actually a
fairly significant thing.
And you can see the results
of that after several years,
that there is definitely
a family resemblance
among their products.
But I want to move to
the third phase of this,
because what we're
actually seeing
is the formation of a new
concept of professional design
practice, which will
lead in a straight line
to where we are today.
Phase three-- phase one was
cardboard boxes and graphics
on them.
Phase two was a consistent
design language.
Phase three was the
suggestion that I
hope will resonate
with some of you
in design at Google, which
is that design can actually
improve the performance
of a product,
not just make it
look good and not
just make a statement
to the external world.
And that happened when a new
guy took over with the idea
that we're going
to embed ourselves
in the various divisions
of Hewlett-Packard--
oscilloscopes,
microwaves, and so on.
And what he did-- his
name was Alan Inhelder.
And he left us just
about a year ago.
But I was able to spend a bunch
of time with him in his retreat
up in Portola Valley.
And he told me the story of how,
as he attempted to establish
credibility within this
insanely engineering driven
environment-- you may hear some
resonances of your experience
here-- he took Hewlett-Packard's
single best selling product,
HP model 608 VHF signal
generator, and made
a facsimile of the
faceplate of it
on a piece of
cardboard, which he then
overlaid with those pieces
of colored masking tape.
That's all you're seeing there.
And his point, as
he presented it
to a very, very skeptical
group of electrical engineers,
was that the design, or the
lack of design of the product,
was completely irrational.
It was completely arbitrary.
It was almost literally as
if the internal workings
of the product had
been established,
and then somebody poked
holes in the face plate
to accommodate the controls
for attenuation, frequency,
modulation, and whatever.
And with a little
bit of forethought,
and a little bit of analysis,
it could be reconfigured.
It was called in those days a
related function and control
link analysis.
That if there were a
clear visual connection
between turning the thing on,
controlling it, and reading out
the display, it could be
easier to use, faster to use,
perhaps even safer to use.
We could perhaps
take up less space,
scarce real estate on
an engineer's bench,
and so on and so forth.
The engineers listened to
him with their skepticism
beginning to melt away.
There was a silence when he
finished his presentation.
And then they gave him
a standing ovation.
And design was established
at Hewlett-Packard.
So that's a beginning story.
And that goes back,
way way before Apple
began to put design
so prominently
in the world's consciousness.
That was back in the
50s and into the '60s.
But for most of the period,
this is what design was.
It was people such
as Harold Lindsay,
chief engineer at Ampex, which
invented magnetic recording.
Actually they stole
it from the Nazis,
but they commercialized
magnetic recording.
Harold Lindsay, the
iconic embodiment
of what I call the engineer
with taste-- nothing
went out of Ampex's
studios that didn't
have his kind of fastidious
attention to detail.
And over about a
decade, the model
of the engineer
with taste evolved
into that of the professionally
trained designer.
That's a guy named
Frank Walsh who
was the first manager of
industrial design at the Ampex
Corporation-- which again
basically no longer exists--
with his friend,
whose name is Elmer
Average, an articulated
anthropometric figure, in which
they're approaching the
task of design in, I'd say,
an almost rigorously
scientific fashion,
not just kind of how it
looks and how it feels
and is it beautiful or not.
So it's starting to happen.
We're starting to get a
professionalization of design
at the two big companies,
Hewlett-Packard and Ampex,
and then a small number
of little operations
that are scattered
around the Bay Area doing
calculating machines and such.
The main characteristic
of design
for most of this period--
for all of this period
thus far is it was strictly
within a very technology
intensive and what we
would call business
to business environment,
which they stayed as far
away from the consumer
market as possible.
The reason is probably
contained in this story.
If any of you have
parents who worked
in engineering in the Valley, or
anywhere else for that matter,
in the 1970s, just show
them a picture of the HP 35
calculator.
And your father-- it'll
probably be your father--
will start to cry.
This is the beloved instrument.
This is the iPhone of the 1970s.
And it's a very, very good
story of why designers remained
confined to this very
technology intensive environment
and those sorts of products.
So what happened here-- I'll
tell the story very quickly,
but it's a good one.
In 1971, Bill Hewlett
conceived the idea
of investing a million bucks.
And in those days, a million
dollars was real money.
It was not down payment on
a dog house in Los Altos.
He conceived the idea of
investing a million dollars
in replacing Hewlett-Packard's
very, very successful desktop
calculator with
a portable device
that an engineer could
stick into his shirt
pocket-- his shirt pocket,
obviously-- and take out
into the field, as a surveyor,
as a mining engineer,
perhaps as an airplane
pilot, perhaps as a surgeon
into an operating room, any kind
of professional environment.
He had to overcome significant
resistance from his business
office, from his
engineering people.
But he was the boss,
so he had his way,
and I would say fortunately.
But here is the thing about it.
In all previous tech products at
Hewlett-Packard and pretty much
elsewhere, the brief
would have begun
with technical specifications.
And it would have been
something like, build
a machine that will execute
transcendental functions using
a pseudo multiplication
algorithm
and displayed in
reverse Polish notation.
And I have absolutely no
idea what I just said.
And then it would be handed
over to the design group
to put it in a box.
And in this case, the sequence
was completely reversed.
So the starting
point was rather--
and I'm quoting Hewlett right
now-- "Give me," quote, a shirt
pocket sized scientific
calculator with four hour
operation from rechargeable
batteries at a cost
that any laboratory
and many individuals
could easily justify."
Not a technical
criterion in there.
So it was, in a sense,
start with the design,
and then give me the
suitable engineering
innards of the thing.
So it was a landmark product.
They estimated that they
would probably sell, I think,
500 of them over the first year.
In the first year, it was just
a complete runaway, blockbuster
success, amounted to 40% of
Hewlett-Packard's profits.
So it sent the message--
it just telegraphed
this powerful message,
design matters.
Design can actually be a
critical driver of a product
and not simply an
aesthetic afterthought.
Unfortunately, it
went to their heads.
They got the idea,
we can do anything.
We were on the cusp of a
new age of miniaturization.
What else can we do?
And it's not just
Hewlett-Packard, but Intel
as well.
So Hewlett-Packard says the
next stage after a calculator,
let's put it on your wrist.
And we're talking wearables
now in the early 1970s.
So they created this
absolutely hideous marvel
of miniaturization, the HP-01
watch calculator whose buttons
have to be pressed by
a little stylus that
was buried in the watchband
that you instantly lost
or used as a toothpick
until it became disgusting.
Engineers loved it, but
it's kind of a dumb thing.
Gordon Moore, similar
idea over at Intel, Moore
of Moore's law, that we have
mastered miniaturization.
We can put $50,000
transistors on a chip.
My god, what else can we do
with our technical savvy?
Let's make a watch.
So they created what I am pretty
sure is the ugliest wristwatch
ever created.
Gordon Moore wore the Intel
Microma on his deathbed.
He referred to it as
his $15 million watch,
because that's how much
money the company lost
on it, as a reminder
never to go anywhere
near the consumer market.
So they understood tech.
They understood the
business environment.
They understood the engineering.
And they didn't
understand anything
about the vagaries
of consumer behavior.
That's terra incognita.
That's death.
There was only one exception
that I can think of a tech firm
in the region venturing
over that forbidden boundary
separating the
professional engineering
world and the consumer market.
And that is, of course, Atari.
How many of you
have played "Pong?"
All of you?
Any of you?
So I lost a very large number
of quarters in "Pong" machines
when I was in graduate school
in Santa Cruz years ago.
But it was pretty much
the only tech product
that I can think of
from the first 30
years of the growth
of this region
as a tech center that was
commercially interesting
and commercially successful.
And in fact Atari
was, for a time,
the fastest growing
and most drug
infused company in
the United States.
For most people however,
design in California
meant either Grateful Dead
posters or the Sunset Magazine
image of a Northern
California lifestyle-- Eichler
houses, glassy atriums,
and that kind of thing,
maybe a little bit of
Eames era furniture.
But as I said at the
beginning, if you thought
about the major centers of
design anywhere in the world,
we were simply not on the map.
And it began to change from
very unexpected quarters.
And I will explain that
just through one example out
of a very large
number, some of which
are discussed in the book.
And it starts here.
I'm sure a lot of you are
familiar with the migration
of personal computing out of the
laboratory environments of what
was then called the
Stanford Research Institute,
and toward the market.
But let me tell it
to you rather briefly
from a design perspective,
which is something
that I was able to get into, and
surprisingly seem not to have
been discussed elsewhere.
So here is the famous Douglas
Engelbart, the inventor
of the workstation.
And we know all about Douglas
Engelbart and the 1968
presentation at the San
Francisco Joint Computer
Conference in which
he demonstrated
remote collaboration through
an interactive computer
experience.
What was not known is that one
of Engelbart's best friends
in this critical period in which
he is exploring the computer
not as a calculating machine but
as an interactive information
and communications machine--
he made friends with a guy
named Robert Propst, who was the
director of the Herman Miller
Research Institute, Herman
Miller office furniture,
a design driven office
furniture company-- still
very much with us and
very much design driven
in Grand Rapids, Michigan.
Propst always thought of himself
more as a philosopher than
as a furniture designer.
And he had become interested in
the changing patterns of work
as we faced a situation
of what everybody now
calls information overload
or the information tsunami.
So he got into the
practice of looking
at what IDEO people like
to call the extreme users.
He had a different
language for it,
but that was people who lived
in a world of hyperinformation.
And he found his way to
Douglas Engelbart's lab,
the Augmentation Research
Institute at Stanford Research
Institute-- Research Center--
where they were developing
the first online system.
So we had the inventor of the
cubicle, called the action
office-- for which he
apologized later in his life,
by the way-- making friends with
the inventor of the workstation
in a really historic
collaboration of design
and engineering.
So Engelbart is sitting
there with-- I'm
afraid you can't make
it out very well,
but it's a plastic tray that's
something like what you would
see in a baby's
high chair, which
has three reservoirs in it,
one containing a keyboard
that was cannibalized off of
an IBM Selectric typewriter,
another device called an X-Y
Position Indicator, which
you better know as a mouse.
And a third is a
five fingered key
set-- they called it a
chord set-- through which
by pressing the keys
in any combination
you could get the
first one an A,
a B, a C, a D,
two together E, F,
the full alphanumeric keyboard.
And Engelbart on
his deathbed was
convinced that that was a
faster way to input data
into a computer than the mouse.
In any case, it
was the designers
from Herman Miller who
helped Engelbart actually
to fashion the program.
So there we have
the first prototype
of an interactive
computing experience, which
is about communication and
getting your work done and not
simply about feeding in rolls
of punch cards in the morning
and pulling out rolls of
paper tape in the afternoon.
He also, interestingly
enough, built a computer
with a display on it,
which was highly, highly
unusual in the 1960s.
It would be like putting a
Plexiglas hood on your car
so that you could
see the engine.
Why would anybody
want to see what's
going on inside the computer?
You put in your cards,
you pulled out your tape.
But for Engelbart, it's
an interactive experience.
And the whole point
is that you are
interacting in a behavioral,
experiential way.
So we pretty much
know the story.
Engelbart was a bit of a nut.
When Xerox Corporation
put $100 million
into opening a new research
center on Coyote Hill
Road in Palo Alto, a bunch
of Engelbart's top scientists
and engineers migrated over
to Xerox Palo Alto Research
Center where they proceeded
to build a working
functional prototype of
an interactive desktop--
or in the words of Alan
Kay, a personal computer.
This is pretty well known.
There are gobs of
books about it.
But I wanted to get into
the design element of it.
And that proved to be a
very, very interesting story.
They brought a designer, an
industrial designer-- actually
the same guy who had
created the design
group at Hewlett-Packard--
to help them figure out
what a personal desktop computer
experience might physically
look like.
Here are some pages on the
right from his notebook.
And on the left this
is Larry Tesler, who
was one of the chief
scientists at Google--
I'm sorry, you're Google-- at
Xerox, who then went to Apple,
playing around conceptually
with what some of these devices
might look like.
So that's the mouse, which he's
imagining as a three button
thing, almost like Morse dash.
Dot-dash, and if you
get frustrated, damn it.
And that's your emergency thing.
The reason I love these
images-- and that's
that five fingered keyset thing.
The reason I love these images
is that for much of design's
history, what
designers were doing
is taking an existing
product and improving it.
So you got this year's
toaster looks like this,
so next year's toaster is
going to look like this.
But if next year's
toaster looks like this,
the year has got to look like
this with a little bit of vinyl
applique on it or something.
What was starting
to happen here is
designers were being challenged
not simply to improve
an existing product, but to give
form to the experience of using
something entirely new.
And that is going to be
the signature, in a sense,
of what became distinctive
about Silicon Valley.
There is no predecessor.
There is no ancestor.
There is no way of
looking backward
to the previous
model of a mouse or
of a desktop personal computer.
There are a couple of images
pilfered from the web,
so I'm not going to linger over
them, of what the Xerox Alto
looked like in the early 1970s.
The industrial designer
Clement creates a keyboard,
which he used the term
garageable into the base
to save space on the desktop.
And they were fond of bringing
faculty brats from Stanford
into experiment
with the computer.
That should be
accessible even to kids.
It's not about knowing
how the computer works,
what's under the keyboard
or behind the screen.
It's about getting
your work done.
Now then the story is a kind
of a familiar one, which
can be sort of summarized here.
The Xerox Corporation,
of course,
determined that they were
in the business of copy
machines and not computing.
That was not much future
for personal computing.
So the core of the Xerox
technical community
proceeded to leave in
indignation or despair
or whatever.
Larry Tesler brings
the GUI experience
to the new Apple Computer.
Two of the chief
guys left to create
a digital formatting
for visual design
at Adobe, Geschke and Warnock.
The networking protocol
created at Xerox PARC-- I mean,
they invented
everything and proceeded
to lose it-- went to 3Com.
Electronic Arts is a
direct descendant--
I'm sorry for the
stupid graphics.
I couldn't resist.
The first laptop computer
was done by Grid Systems,
a guy named John Ellenby.
Charles Simonyi left Xerox
to bring his word processing
protocols, which was
rebooted as Microsoft Word.
And it's a little
bit unfair to say
that Xerox PARC disappeared.
It's still there and it's
a very distinguished,
important laboratory.
But they watched
in dismay as one
after another of the
components of their system
became implanted in some of
the most successful companies
of the Valley today.
This is finally where
Apple enters the picture.
And the computer that
you're seeing here
is the Apple II, which is not
much to look at in some ways,
but I actually think is probably
the single most important
artifact from a design point
of view in this entire history.
And it's simply for this reason.
Jobs had the idea that for
every hardware enthusiastic who
wanted to buy a kit and
solder together a board
and build his-- usually
his-- own computer,
there were a thousand software
enthusiasts out there who
simply wanted to take
it out of the box,
plug it in, put a monitor on
top of it, and get to work.
So they made a gamble, in
1977, of selling a computer
in a sealed case.
And I know that doesn't
sound like much,
but I actually think
that that decision
is pretty close to the
seminal turning points that
began to pivot design from a
strictly technology environment
and toward the consumer market.
Because as soon as they
raised that question
of selling a computer that only
a trained professional could
or would be interested
in opening up,
then every other question
of design followed.
What should that case look like?
How approachable should it be?
What connection should it make,
visually and experiential,
to every other thing
on your desktop,
and so on and so forth?
And it began the entire
process of expanding
the perimeter around what
we consider design to be.
And of course to
do that he begins
to tap into this emerging
community of many Stanford
graduates who are setting up one
and two and three person design
firms up and down
University Avenue.
Knocks on the door
of one guy, Jerry
Manock, and said can you create
the case for the Apple II?
Manock said I can
do it, but you've
got to pay me in advance.
This was the third try
that Jobs had made.
I personally know three other
people that turned him down
on the spot.
And they're still
kicking themselves.
I mean, would you invest
a lot of your time,
like $1,800 worth of
free time, in a startup
founded on April
Fool's Day, 1976,
and named after
a piece of fruit?
So that was the environment.
But a couple of
people were willing.
David Kelley's group of half
a dozen Stanford graduates
above Roxy's dress shop
on University Avenue,
took on the problem of a mouse.
Job said, I saw this
device at Xerox PARC.
It cost $400 to make.
The mouse had to be disassembled
at the end of each day,
every component cleaned,
and then reassembled
so that it could be used the
next day by the researchers.
Jobs said, can you
make one that will
cost $20 that I
can use on my jeans
and that doesn't require
that kind of maintenance?
Think of it not as an
instrument but an appliance.
And they looked at each other,
of course we can do a mouse.
And so they signed the
contract and Jobs left.
And somebody said,
does anybody know
what a mouse is,
very much capturing
what's beginning to happen
at that critical period.
And then it is very much
an Apple dominated story.
Apple is becoming
internationally notorious,
partly for its design.
And the decision is made by
Jobs himself and his inner core
that it's time to
grow up and establish
a globally significant
design language.
So they launched a program
called the Snow White
competition in which they
sought out half a dozen
of the world's leading
designers, all European.
Narrowed it down to
two, an English group
called BAB, which created
a series of prototypes.
The computer is
Snow White and then
seven dwarf like
peripherals around it.
And a small firm
in the Black Forest
then called Esslinger
Design, which
becomes Frog Design,
which created
the softer and more
approachable off-white language.
And we are very much
off and running.
So this is really the story.
It's the migration of a
pure technical product,
Douglas Engelbart's original
interactive computer,
from a science fair project
almost to a working prototype
to a commercial product.
And what's significant
for our story,
this happens within
the circumference
of an easy bicycle ride.
And we could repeat that
story with surgical robotics,
with electronic
gaming, with any number
of other artifacts of
the Valley, each of which
will engender a whole
new field of design.
So for instance, Atari
invents game design.
How many game designers do
you think Nolan Bushnell
hired in 1971 when he's getting
this company off the ground?
The answer, zero.
Why?
There was no such thing.
He was hiring software
engineers, programmers,
computer scientists, drug
addicts, comic book writers,
anybody he could find who
could craft a story in code.
10 years later he was
hiring game designers.
A new field had emerged.
The same thing will happen
then with interaction design,
a combo of traditional graphic
design, computer science.
And we have a new field.
And we are seeing this
over and over again.
So the story then,
wrapping up, begins
to look something like this.
In the case of
personal computing,
this sort of migration, the
formation of service companies,
which are design intensive.
And this does not mean
that they all get on buses
and go to the beach, but
rather they start to calve off
their own smaller companies.
And where we are today, which
I find simply extraordinary,
is the last stage
of my story, which
is the expansion of
the range of problems
that designers are now, in a
sense, authorized to work on.
So moving from
packaging electronics
to dealing with problems
of global poverty,
of public health access,
of design education,
of ethical problems,
often under the name--
of the highly controversial
name of design thinking.
But it is, in many
respects, the conclusion
of a story that
goes back 65 years.
So that's kind of
where we are now.
Design has not been supplanted
by design thinking, whatever
we try to tell you at Stanford.
But we have built into
our consciousness,
in a sense, the idea that
the methods and methodologies
and strategies of the designer,
this toolkit that we've
been building for half a
century, some of those tools
can be applied to
pretty much any problem
that you can think of.
So thank you for
your attention there.
I will conclude with the
original-- this is actually
the awesome button,
as it was then
called by a small startup
up on University Avenue
called The Facebook, which a guy
named Soleio Cuervo was asked
if he could improve the
upward pointing thumb
and redrew the 16 by
16 pixel image that
was in an ugly shade of green.
And it turned into one of the
most widely recognized symbols
in the world.
So I'll conclude on that note.
I hoped you liked
what you heard.
And if you read the book,
I hope you enjoy it.
[APPLAUSE]
And I hope I did
not talk too long.
But I think we have 10 minutes
for any questions or comments.
And I am particularly
interested in hearing
from the perspective of
Googlers how well this sounds
and whether it corresponds, in
any way, to your own experience
here.
Please.
AUDIENCE: So what
do you think is
the future of design agencies?
At the beginning
of your talk you
showed how both
designers migrated
to larger companies,
a lot of acquisitions
by big companies
of design agencies.
I think part of that is in the
last decade, a lot of agencies
have really sold design
as a strategic asset.
And companies have
realized if they
want to take advantage of that,
they need to bring it in-house.
So how do you see that trend
playing out for agencies?
BARRY KATZ: It's a very,
very good question.
I don't like to make
predictions because I'm
wrong about everything that
I've ever-- I'm a historian,
so I'm good at
looking backwards.
Having said that, I'll make
a couple of predictions.
One of which is one of the
things that we are seeing--
and it's a little bit
alarming-- is a kind
of a tightening of the
pipeline within many
of the independent
consultancies,
as many of the big
companies-- you
know, I referred to Google
as a big vacuum cleaner,
which is sucking a lot of
talent out of the consultancies,
some of which are sitting
in this room at this moment.
You may be one.
I don't know.
And that is unlikely to abate.
So in a sense, it's very good
news for the design community.
It may be problematic for the
independent consultancies.
The effect on the
consultancies is, in part, they
are exploring how the skills
that they have acquired
over their various
histories can be
expanded and
diversified and applied
in different directions.
And I think that is
actually one of the drivers
of this whole design
thinking movement.
A second thing is
somewhat, I would
say actually somewhat ominous.
Which is that there are a
lot of organizations which
don't have much of
a product history--
banks, financial
services, foundations,
governmental organizations--
which have been hearing
the buzz about design
thinking, and will send
some of their execs to do a
program in design thinking
or get a certificate
in it or whatever,
and then are building an
internal design thinking team
within their bank or within
their insurance company
or their accounting firm,
Deloitte, or whatever.
This has been happening, I
think you said the last decade.
I think it's actually even
more recent than that.
And so we don't yet have
a longitudinal database
to see how successful
this is going to be.
One sense that I
have is that there
are a lot of people
who are tacking up
their design
thinking certificates
on the walls of their
cool new studios.
And within a few weeks,
the Post-it notes
are beginning to flutter
down, and they're not
quite sure what to do.
So one of the things
that is telling me
is that there is a very
significant difference
between thinking like a
designer and being a designer.
And it's not that one is
better than the other,
but they are very different.
And companies,
organizations have
to be very clear about
what they are getting
and what they are not getting.
I think that a design thinking
sensibility is wonderful
if it gives people
a sense of when
you need to hire
a real designer,
and when you need to engage that
kind of professional service.
So it is one thing to prototype
a product concept in a bank,
in the cool studio somewhere.
But I can tell you, because
I teach in a design school--
we'll have one of
our second year
industrial design
students come in.
We'll give them an assignment.
We want you to do
a ballpoint pen.
I just made that up.
And the kid comes
in with a concept.
And you say OK, that's great.
Come back next Thursday
with 100 iterations of it.
And they're never
going to do that
in the design thinking SWAT
squad within an organization.
So there is a place for this
design as a strategic asset.
And there is clearly a place
for the deep professional skills
that are very, very
hard won over the course
of a serious design education.
I hope that speaks to
your kind of question.
Yeah, please?
AUDIENCE: How could one
be an engineer with taste?
BARRY KATZ: An
engineer with taste--
the question is how can somebody
become an engineer with taste?
Why, are you an engineer
who is seeking to--
That was a phrase that
I used in connection
with-- I guess Harold Lindsay
was employee two at Ampex way
back in the '50s.
And he did have this
just impeccable sense
of beauty, symmetry, finish.
And he never wanted any
of the recording machines
to leave his scrutiny
that wasn't perfect.
Employee one at
Ampex, by the way--
I'm avoiding your
question, but I'll
try to get back to it-- was
a guy named Myron Stolaroff.
And I gotta tell you
this story in case
you don't know about him.
In much of the universe, we
have the technical engineering
community off to this side.
And they're sitting in
cubicles doing problem sets
and coding and whatever.
And then you have the drug
music, arts people off
on this side.
In much of Silicon Valley
they were the same person,
and still are.
And there's a little
bit of a legacy of that.
Myron Stolaroff was a
very, very highly trained
electrical engineer, and the
first employee at Ampex in 1949
I think.
He has also consumed,
so far as we
know, more LSD than
any other human
being on the planet Earth.
And he was in the habit-- maybe
this will answer your question,
I don't know.
But he was dealing
with this problem
that we call the problem
of a disruptive technology,
that you're trained to
think in one paradigm
and according to one
mental framework.
And that was, for him,
it was pressing wax disks
to make music recordings.
And the whole
technology paradigm
had shifted to this
idea that you can embed
sound in iron particles
embedded in magnetic tape.
And his engineers were
trying to think one way,
and they were being
asked to think
completely out of the box.
How are we going to do that?
So he was in the habit of
packing up three or four
of his senior engineers into
the back of his station wagon
every weekend and driving
them out to his summer house
in the Sierras and filling
them full of LSD, in 1950, '51.
He lost a few of them.
And others, such as
Ray Dolby, went on
to do some fairly
significant work.
So I'm not going to go
on record as suggesting
that you go that route, although
I know a fair number of people
now who are reviving an interest
in that particular phenomenon.
I think probably
my serious answer
to that is it's not
taking a course with Barry
Katz at Stanford or
anything like that.
It's probably by recognizing
that most creative work now
happens in teams.
And what I've seen,
especially at IDEO,
it used to be that you would be
see a bunch of people sitting
around a table, and you'd say
which one is the designer.
So here's the designer
and here's the EE.
Thomas, are you still here?
And here's somebody from
the manufacturing side.
And now we're
increasingly thinking
of a design team, almost an
undifferentiated group in which
people have different
competencies,
but they are approaching
their projects
as a kind of an
integrated design problem.
And there's got to be
something they're absorbing,
some of the skills and
mindsets of people with very
different sorts of training.
That may or may not lead
you in that direction.
It's a nice question.
I will meditate further.
I think we have time
for-- yeah, please?
AUDIENCE: I'm curious to
get your perspective on,
I guess the coalescing
of design research
from a lot of different
perspectives, maybe
[INAUDIBLE] disciplinary
disciplines coming together,
and where you see that kind
of going down the line?
BARRY KATZ: Yeah, I think
it's a wonderful question.
It was about the coalescing
of design and research.
So one of the ways
that I think about it--
it was one of those three
questions that I ask.
It was sort of embedded
in that and I don't really
think I unpacked it with
much clarity in the talk.
But in the course of
certainly the 65 year history
that I have looked at, one of
the really striking features
of that history is the
expansion of the perimeter
around what we
call design and who
we need to be part
of that process
and what skills we
need to be acquiring.
So I often like to tell the
story-- it's very much an IDEO
story, but I think it
will resonate here.
The company started
in about 1980
with a rather
unusual combination
of industrial design and
mechanical engineering.
And a decade later, they began
to build a social science
competence into that with
the hiring of a woman named
Jane Fulton Suri who has a
background both in psychology
and architecture, which
have unpredictable points
of collision there.
Why bring in a
consultant afterwards
to figure out what was
wrong with this machine
such that a guy just chopped
off his finger on it?
Why don't you look at it
before the accident happened?
So that began a process of
adding social psychologists,
anthropologists, ethnographers.
I have a friend there who has
a PhD in behavioral economics.
So we're seeing the expansion
of the perimeter around
what is necessary to approach
the insane complexity of what
may seem like an
extremely simple product.
And I see that-- I hope this
speaks to your question.
I see that as only expanding.
I mean I think we are continuing
to ask, what new competence do
we need to build in in
order to grapple with that?
So I'm hearing about
sociologists at Google,
and I'm hearing about
writers being employed
in various companies
not simply to document
a story of a project
after it's completed,
but to use narrative strategies
to drive a story forward
from the outset.
So I think it's a
wonderful question,
but a very much open minded
one-- open ended one,
and I hope open minded as well.
MARIA: Thank you so much Barry.
We're out of time, but if
you can stay and ask for--
BARRY KATZ: Happy to.
MARIA: --[INAUDIBLE]
BARRY KATZ: Thank
you very much folks.